[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Marietta slomker guten Abend
als eine neue PIs Studie angekündigt
wurde mit der die OECD die
Schulleistungen in über 80
Industriestaaten vergleicht ahnte man
schon dass das für Deutschland nicht
sonderlich erfreulich würde es hatte
zuletzt ja schon viele Klagen gegeben
dass das Leistungsniveau an deutschen
Schulen abgefallen sei nun ist die
Studie da und promt ist wieder von einem
pisaschock die Rede so wie vor gut 20
Jahren als die erste PIs Studie
veröffentlicht wurde danach wurden die
Ergebnisse besser aber jetzt wieder ein
gewaltiger Abfall gegenüber dem letzten
Vergleich von
2018 an den coronchulschließungen allein
kann es nicht liegen so viel sei vorweg
schon gesagt Ergebnisse Erklärungen und
Reaktionen hat stefhanie
he hier wird der Grundstein für
Lebenswege gelegt Lesen Schreiben
Rechnen lernen an der Grundschule sollen
Kinder die gleichen Fähigkeiten erwerben
doch schon bei den Kleinsten sind die
Unterschiede enorm beobachtet die
Berliner Schulleiterin Karina jäniche
wenn Kinder in die erste Klasse kommen
und noch keinen Stift halten können
keine Schere halten können dann wird's
schwierig dann brauchen wir über
inhaltliche Dinge des Unterrichts noch
gar nicht zu sprechen diese Unterschiede
ziehen sich durch ganze Schulkarrieren
so sieht es im aktuellen pisatest unter
den 15-Jährigen in Deutschlands Schulen
düster aus die Lesekompetenz etwa hat
abgenommen in den Naturwissenschaften
haben die Ergebnisse deutlich
nachgelassen und die erreichten Punkte
in Mathe so wenig wie nie zuvor mit
verheerenden Folgen was wir sehen ist
z.B dass drei von Zeh Schüler
Schülerinnen und Schüler in Mathematik
unter dem Mindestniveau liegen das heißt
sie haben große Schwierigkeiten auch im
Alltag z.B beim Einkaufen sich zu
überlegen ob sich ein Sonderangebot
lohnt die Organisation für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung hat weltweit 15-jährige
getestet den durchschnittlichen
Leistungsrückgang im ecdraum insgesamt
nennt sie beispiellos Deutschland im
Durchschnitt oder kaum darüber Lücken
durch Corona sieht der Generalsekretär
der bundesschülerkonferenz als eine
Ursache dazu die Chancenungleichheit und
vor allem der Lehrermangel es kann nicht
sein dass Lehrkräfte einerseits
Lehrkräfte sind gleichzeitig
Bibliothekare pausenausichten und
schulsozial schulszialarbeiter ich libt
auch in eigen Haut bei mir fällt oft
Unterricht aus da muss ich mir selber
Sachen beibringen mit Schulbücher mit
Youtube Videos aber für uns ist ganz
klar das ist kein Ersatz für Lehrkräfte
denn Lehrerinnen und Lehrer wirden nicht
nur für die Vermittlung von Wissen
gebraucht es geht hier um
Beziehungsarbeit und darum Schülerinnen
und Schülern eine gute
Zukunftsperspektive aufzuzeigen dann
wird immer gefragt nach den geflüchteten
Schülerinnen und nach den Schülern mit
Migrationshintergrund und
nach Schülerinnen aus
präären
Familienverhältnissen und so und das
stimmt alles aber das stimmt deswegen
weil eben gerade die
so sich so schwer tun eine
Zukunftsperspektive zu entwickeln dazu
kommt der Anteil der Kinder mit
Migrationshintergrund hat sich in den
letzten 10 Jahren verdoppelt sprich es
fehlen oft Deutschkenntnisse mehr
frühkindliche Bildung ist dringend
nötig wir müssen gucken dass wir nicht
erst diese Kinder in der Schule dann
bemerken die Defizite dieser Kinder die
Problematiken der Kinder weil es dann
eigentlich immer nur noch ums aufholen
geht und das belastet nicht nur die
Erwachsenen son es belastet ja auch die
Kinder nach dem ersten PIs Test vor gut
20 Jahren war Deutschland geschockt
jetzt sind die Ergebnisse noch
schlechter t ein Zeichen dafür dass
insbesondere mit dem
Mathematikunterricht an vielen Schulen
etwas nicht gut läuft ist der enorme
Erfolg sogenannter Youtube Lehrer die
Erklärvideos im Internet anbieten und
damit offenkundig eine Lücke füllen eine
der bekanntesten ist Daniel jung und er
ist nachher im heute journal Update zu
Gast der Außenminister der Ukraine
diitro Leber hat heute gesagt dass
niemand anders als Kiev darüber
entscheiden werde ob man in
Verhandlungen mit Russland
Eintritt allein die Tatsache dass er das
betonen muss spricht Bände natürlich
wird in der Ukraine befürchtet dass die
Unterstützung des Westens nachlässt und
unter den Regierungen die Zahl derer
wächst die mit Putin bereits jetzt
verhandeln möchten zu einem Zeitpunkt an
dem er selbst dafür noch nicht den
geringsten Anlass sieht im Gegenteil
ganz abgesehen davon dass er letztens
erst einen seiner Generäle öffentlich
erklären ließ die Ukraine sei eh nur der
Anfang dazu gleich ein Gespräch mit
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius zuvor
berichtet Christian Kirsch über die
prekäre Lage auf den ukrainischen
Schlachtfeldern
aftiivka ein schreckensort seit Wochen
Rennen russische Soldaten hier gegen
ukrainische Verteidiger an offenbar mit
hohen Verlusten auf beiden
Seiten der Ukraine mangelt es an
Munition und auch an Soldaten es ist ein
abnutzungskrieg sie greifen die ganze
Zeit an wir verlieren sehr viele
Soldaten man hat keine Kraft mehr gegen
sie zu kämpfen sie beschießen uns mit
Artillerie und mit drohen
Erschöpfung und der oberste Soldat der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte nicht immer
einer Meinung mit Präsident selenski
sagt der Krieg befe sich in ein
Sackgasse bedeutendster Unterstützer der
Ukraine bleiben die USA doch hier im
Kongress in Washington stößt Präsident
Biden mit seinen hilfsplänen auf
Widerstand 61 Milliarden für Kiev
fordert der Präsident manche
Republikaner sind
dagegen ich glaube dass jeder
Kongressabgeordnete der nicht für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine stimmt es
Putin erleichtert sich durchzusetzen
eine Stimme gegen die Unterstützung der
Ukraine ist eine Stimme für Putin
auch hier in Brüssel ein ähnliches Bild
grundsätzliche Solidarität mit der
Ukraine aber ein 50 Milliarden
Hilfspaket kommt nicht wirklich voran
ein Diplomat spricht von einem Gefühl
der Müdigkeit ohne Unterstützung aus
Europa und Amerika kann die Ukraine
allerdings diesen Krieg nicht
überleben fachleute warnen vor einer
Überlastung der ukrainischen
Verteidiger icht in den große Teile der
Truppen also der ukrainischen Truppen
durchaus erschöpft sind also die
Möglichkeit der Rotation ist kaum
gegeben teilweise sind Truppenteile nur
bis zu 60% befüllt das ist eine
irsinnige große Belastung und natürlich
die Kämpfe die geführt werden die
Abwehrkämpfe gegen ein russisches
vorrücken das alles kulminiert jetzt zu
so einem Punkt wo viele dieser
Streitkräfte ganz einfach zwar noch
Kampfeswillen haben aber physisch sehr
erschöpft
sind kievs Bürgermeister
fel wieder auf mit offener Kritik am
Präsidenten forderte realitätssin stad
Patos selbstverständlich können wir
ehorisch unser Volk und unsere Partner
anlügen aber das können wir nicht ewig
machen und jetzt die Ukraine abhängig
von westlicher Unterstützung will und
wird
weiterkämpfen für unsere Frauen und
Kinder sind wir bereit hier bis zum Ende
zu stehen und wirerden bis zum Ende
stehen wenn wir das nicht tun wer denn
sonst sie wollen durchhalten jetzt kommt
der
Winter der Bundesverteidigungsminister
ist uns zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
pesturius guten Abend Frau Slomka sie
kennen die Kritik dass die Ukraine zum
tja zum Gewinnen zu wenig zum Verlieren
zu viel bekommt haben das bisher
eigentlich immer zurückgewiesen wenn
dieser Vorwurf formuliert wurde warum
ist der eigentlich falsch nach der
aktuellen Lage na ich habe ihn immer
zurückgewiesen weil er tatsächlich
falsch ist wir liefern was wir können
das gilt für fast alle anderen
Verbündeten und Partner auch wir haben
gerade das Problem das ist bekannt dass
die Rüstungsindustrie in bestimmten
Bereichen nicht so schnell liefern kann
wie die Bedarfe da sind das beginnt bei
der Munition das geht weiter über
luftverteidigungssysteme wir liefern als
Deutschland äh wahnsinnig viel wir sind
inzwischen der zweitgrößte Unterstützer
mit großem Abstand vor den anderen und
und das betrifft vor allen Dingen die
Bereiche die für die Ukraine jetzt im
zweiten Kriegswinter so wichtig sind
also Luftabwehr Luftverteidigung und so
weiter aber Herr Pest wenn wir so
wahnsinnig viel liefern und überhaupt
alle liefern was sie können dann hieße
das ja im Prinzip dass der vereinte
gemeinsame Westen alles liefert was er
kann und nicht in der Lage ist einen
Angriffskrieg zurückzuweisen das ist
nicht gerade eine beruhigende
Vorstellung na ja wir sind erstens ja
nicht Bündnispartner der Ukraine das
heißt wir sind außerhalb eines
bündnisfalls wir reden gleich über ein
Russland das trotz Sanktionen weiter
produziert wenn auch nicht das
hochmodernste Material aber es ist ja
nicht so dass wir nur liefern und aus
Russland nichts Neues für die russischen
Streitkräfte nachkommt das ist halt der
Verlauf eines Krieges wie man ihn nur
schwer vorhersehen kann und deswegen
sind wir in der Situation in der wir
sind und deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir weitermachen deswegen ist es wichtig
und notwendig vor allen Dingen auf
Nachhaltigkeit der Lieferung zu setzen
bei allen Engpässen die es geben kann
aber warum wden dann die
Produktionskapazitäten nicht massiv
hochgefahren also wenn das die Logik ist
wir müssen jetzt einen abnutzungskrieg
die Ukraine unterstützen das ist ein
Krieg der Ressourcen Russland produziert
was es nur kann und das ist eine ganze
Menge sehr viel mehr als die Ukraine
warum werden diese
Produktionskapazitäten nicht
hochgefahren warum fängt die
Rüstungsindustrie jetzt nicht an Panzer
im großen Stil und ähnliches zu bauen
das tut sie ja sie fährt hoch die
Kapazitäten wo immer sie kann aber sie
wissen ja das ist eine Frage des Tempos
und das Tempo kann man nicht unbegrenzt
beeinflussen das braucht Zeit eine
Fabrik hoch zu ziehen die entsprechend
munitions und explosivstoffvorräte
anzulegen um dann schnell und zügig
produzieren zu können wir haben es
gezeigt wie schnell das ging bei der
Gepard Munition die wir in Deutschland
neu auflegen mussten in der Produktion
das hat aber auch se Monate gedauert das
heißt wir reden über Zeitabläufe die man
beschleunigen aber nicht komplett außer
Kraft setzen kann aber ist es nicht
eigenartig dass die Europäer noch nicht
malh schaffen ihre eine Millionen
artilleriebeschusstillerieschuss bis
früher nächsten Jahres bereitzustellen
ich meine die ges gesamte EU schafft das
nicht das ist doch eigentlich
beängstigend ja es ist aber weniger ein
Problem der Europäischen Union ich habe
sehr früh vor dieser Zahl gewarnt weil
ich sah dass diese Zahl mutmaßlich nicht
würde erreicht werden
können das ist eben man man schürt eben
Erwartung die man am Ende nicht erfüllen
kann eine Million war für eine
Rüstungsindustrie die aus Friedenszeiten
kommt eben nicht so ohne weiteres
herstellbar dass das jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten besser wird davon
können Sie ausgehen wir werden allein
aus Deutschland fast 200.000 schussmun
liefern und in den Folgejahren das
aufwachsen sehen aber es braucht halt
alles seine Zeit und das ist keine Frage
politischer Entscheidung oder
finanzieller Mittel na ja was man
liefert ist ja schon eine politische
Entscheidung also wenn man nicht Taurus
liefert wenn man Angst hat dass die
Ukrainer dann die kerschbrücke damit
zerstören wenn man bestimmte
Präzisionswaffen mit langer Reichweite
nicht liefert wen man Angst hat dass
dann russische Stellungen außerhalb der
Ukraine beschossen werden sind das ja
politische Entscheidungen ich fand es
ganz interessant dass der frühere
natooberbefehlshaber breedl gerade in
der Berliner Zeitung im Interview sagte
führende westliche Politiker wollen gar
nicht dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt weil sie davor Angst haben nee
das sehe ich genau anders ich glaube wir
sollten eher Angst davor haben dass
Russland diesen Krieg gewinnt dass Putin
diesen Krieg gewinnt denn dann stehen
wir vor einer völlig neuen
Sicherheitslage in Deutschland von daher
halte ich diesen Vorwurf für völlig
unbegründet und man kann ih auch nicht
festmachen an der Frage ob man ein
bestimmtes System liefert oder nicht
sehen das denn alle in ihrer Partei und
sieht der Bundeskanzler das genauso oder
wird man nicht vielleicht dann doch
gerade auch wenn man so ein nächst
Wahlkämpfe denkt na ja dann doch lieber
auf Verhandlungen drängen die Ukraine
also zum einen sind wir uns alle einig
darüber dass
die einzigen die entscheiden können ob
verhandelt wird oder nicht die Ukraine
und Russland sind und unsere Aufgabe
unsere Verantwortung das sehen wir sehr
klar so ist eine Situation auf dem auf
dem Schlachtfeld auf dem im
Kriegsgeschehen herbeizuführen dass
Putin erkennt der kann diesen Krieg
nicht gewinnen und deshalb an den
Verhandlungstisch kommt äh aber klar ist
wenn wir darauf setzen sollten
irgendjemand darauf setzen sollte wir
wir verlängern den Krieg oder wir
drängen jemanden zu
friedensverhandlung da muss man wissen
dass wenn Putin diesen Krieg gewinnen
sollte wird die Situation eine andere
dann sind Georgien und Moldawien in
Gefahr das balkum und das Baltikum
könnte ebenfalls folgen und dann würden
wir über einen Bündnisfall reden und
deswegen spreche ich ja seit einiger
Zeit immer wieder sehr deutlich davon
dass wir uns anders aufstellen müssen
aber dass irgendjemand ein Interesse
daran hat die Ukraine nur halbherzig zu
unterstützen das kann ich in Deutschland
mit und bei den westlichen Alliierten
nicht erkennen der verhandlungsa ist
noch nicht mal erhöht
worden was heißt das na das heißt dass
der in den nächsten Jahren der reguläre
der reguläre
verteidigungsittchldung ich habe ich
versprochen ja verteidigungsitt der ist
noch nicht mal erhöht worden und die
Haushaltslage der Bundesregierung
darüber brauchen wir gar nicht sprechen
wie wie katastrophal die gerade ist ich
bin da ich bin da ganz entspannt fraulke
zum einen haben wir im kommenden Jahr
wenn der Bundestag das beschließt 71,5
Milliarden Euro für die Verteidigung der
Bundesrepublik das ist der höchste
Betrag für die Bundeswehr in der
Geschichte in der eigenen Geschichte und
ab 27 28 wenn das Sondervermögen
aufgebraucht wird aufgebraucht sein wird
dann wird es Entscheidung geben müssen
die werden im nächsten Jahr vorbereitet
werden und dann muss der
verteidigungseta wachsen damit wir
dieser Verantwortung für unsere
Sicherheit gerecht werden können und das
Wissen alleus danke für das Gespräch
sehr
gerne das Interview haben wir
aufgezeichnet der ukrainische Präsident
hat am Abend einen geplanten
videoauftritt vor dem US-Kongress
überraschend abgesagt näheres ist dazu
noch nicht bekannt wichtig war ihm der
Termin mit Sicherheit schließlich droht
der Wegfall der ukrainhilfe wenn die
Republikaner ihre haushaltsblockade
nicht aufgeben und mit den deutschen
Haushaltsproblemen beginnen jetzt bei
dir die Nachrichten g ja da scheint
weiter keine Einigung in Sicht seit dem
frühen Abend beraten im Kanzleramt
hinter verschlossenen Türen Kanzler
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck und
Finanzminister Lindner sollten Sie sich
in den nächsten Stunden auf Kompromisse
verständigen könnten diese morgen
Vormittag im Bundeskabinett beschlossen
werden nur wenn dieser Zeitplan
eingehalten wird könnte der Bundestag
den et 24 noch in diesem Jahr
verabschieden Israels Armee hat die
Angriffe im Süden des Gazastreifens
massiv ausgeweitet und stößt mit dem
Vorgehen international zunehmend auf
Kritik nach UN-Angaben steigt die Zahl
der getöteten Zivilisten rapide
aufgeschätzt fast 16 000 die
evakuierungsbefehle drängten zudem die
Menschen in knapp einem Drittel des
gaserstreifens zusammen laut UN fehlen
Nahrung Wasser Zelte und vor allem
Sicherheit nach Medienberichten plant
Israel über diese Angriffe hinaus die
von der Hamas genutzten Tunnelsysteme im
Gazastreifen unter was zu
setzen Israel reagierte außerdem erneut
auf Beschuss auch an der nördlichen
Grenze zum Libanon immer wieder kommt es
dort zu Konfrontationen mit der
Hisbollah die mit der Hamas verbunden
ist dabei wurde jetzt erstmals in diesem
aktuellen Konflikt ein libanesischer
Soldat
getötet der weltweite Ausstoß
klimaschädlicher CO2 Emissionen durch
fossile Energieträger wie Kohle und Gas
wird in diesem Jahr ein Rekordhoch
erreichen allerdings einer
internationalen Studie zufolge sanken
die Emissionen in den USA um 3 und in
der EU um gut
7%. dagegen stiegen die
Kohlendioxidwerte in den beiden
bevölkerungsreichsten Ländern in Indien
etwa um 8% und in China wurden 4% mehr
CO2
ausgestoßen zu den klimaschutzplänen der
Bundesregierung gehörte ja auch in
Deutschland mehr Elektroautos auf die
Straße zu kriegen im Moment fahren hier
zu Lande rund anderthalb Millionen bis
2030 sollen es 15 Millionen sein das war
natürlich eh schon ein ziemlich
ehrgeiziges Ziel zumal die
Ampelkoalition in ihrer politischen
Uneinigkeit zugleich auch noch den
Verbrenner schützt aber jetzt mit der
Haushaltskrise dürfte das noch
schwieriger werden E-Mobilität zu
fördern für die deutschen Autobauer
stellt sich oben drauf das Problem dass
ihn die Chinesen elektrisch davon fahren
bei BMW hatten sie heute immerhin die
Gelegenheit ihre Sorgen an den Mann zu
bringen der Kanzler war zu Besuch
beobachtet haben das Alexander Pool und
Peter
aumeierer für den Kanzler ist Zeit
kostbar in diesen Krisentagen und doch
hat Olaf Scholz ungewöhnlich viel davon
mitgebracht ins Stammwerk von BMW nach
München der Autobauer steckt mitten in
der Transformation wie eigentlich das
ganze Land und so bedient sich Olaf
Scholz ob absichtlich oder nicht am
Wortschatz ein
altkanzlerin wer hier Produktion sieht
und die ganzen Veränderung begleiten
kann der geht hier weg mit dem sicheren
Gefühl das wird uns gelingen das wird
unser Land schaffen und bmwchef Oliver
Zipse tut etwas was man von
erfolgreichen Unternehmern selten hört
in diesen Tagen er bekennt sich zum
Standort Deutschland Herr Bundeskanzler
sie haben die BMW Group als Partner in
dem
Transformationsprozess wir glauben
Industrialisierung in Deutschland hat
eine Zukunft schöne Worte die ihm wenig
helfen Oliver Simon Finanzchef der
mittelständischen Heinemann Group sein
Unternehmen baut rund um München
Ladesäulen für E-Autos dass in der
derzeitigen Haushaltskrise die Förderung
von E-Mobilität wegfallen könnte für
Simon ein Grund zur Sorge die
Bundesregierung plant ja eine Million
öffentliche Ladepunkte errichtet zu
haben bis Jahr 2030 wir sind stand jetzt
ziemlich genau bei 95 000 eine
Mammutaufgabe wenn in dem Zusammenhang
dann noch Förderungen wegfallen für
Elektromobilität gibt es wahrscheinlich
weiterhin einen ist ein Bremsklotz der
uns im Ausbau zurückhalten wird Simon
fürchtet um sein Geschäft wenn vom 1
Januar an Gewerbekunden keine
e-autoprämie mehr bekommen werden
weniger Ladesäulen gebraucht seit
bekannt werden des milliardenls im
Haushalt steht nun auch die Umweltprämie
für privat Ken zur Diskussion experten
warnen vor einem solchen Schritt nach
wie vor sind die Elektroautos sehr sehr
teuer im Vergleich zu
verbrennerfahrzeugen und diese
Umweltprämie haben diesen diesen großen
Preisunterschied zwischen Elektroautos
und Verbrennern zum Teil aufgehoben zum
Teil die Autos dann eben attraktiver
gemacht Wirtschaftsfachleute halten die
Umweltprämie für einen falschen Anreiz
und appellieren an die Vernunft der
Autokäufer fahren mit Verbrenner werde
künftig ohnehin teurer wir müssen sehen
dass vor allem der CO2 Preis da zum Zuge
kommt das heißt es muss sich lohnen
Elektroautos zu kaufen weil Benzin mit
seiner Klimabelastung teurer WD klar ist
das Ziel der Bundesregierung bis 2030 15
Millionen E-Autos auf die Straße zu
bringen ist sehr ambitioniert bei seinem
Besuch bei BMW aber wollte der Kanzler
davon erstmal nicht
abrücken und wie es heute auf
Deutschlands Straßen so zuging damit
geht's jetzt bei dir weiterund Schnee
Fälle gefrierender Regen und Glatteis
haben auch heute wieder den Verkehr
beeinträchtigt erneut stand der Betrieb
am Flughafen München stundenlang still
und auch im Bahnverkehr kam es zu
Verzögerungen obwohl Räumdienste im
Einsatz sind in Sachsen streifte ein Bus
ein Streufahrzeug und prallte daraufhin
frontal gegen einen Baum ein Junge kam
ums Leben 13 weitere Insassen erlitten
Verletzungen auf glatten Straßen kam es
zu Zahl reichen
Unfällen zu viel Bürokratie ein
Dauerthema dessen sich auch der
Arbeitgeberverband Gesamtmetall
angenommen hat und mit einer
bundesweiten Umfrage nun den Druck auf
die Bundesregierung erhöhen will Sina
meinitz es ist ein Ergebnis dieser
Umfrage kaum jemand in der Metall und
Elektroindustrie hat überhaupt
mitbekommen dass Bürokratie abgebaut
werden soll so ist es Bürokratie lähmt
das wird bei den rund 900 Befragten
nehmen ganz deutlich von A wie Antrag
bis Z wie Zulassung verhindert dieser
Aufwand einen schnellen und
reibungslosen Ablauf florierender
Geschäfte in den letzten 5 Jahren sind
die bürokratiehürden für die Unternehmen
sogar noch höher geworden Gewinneinbußen
nur langsam umsetzbare Projekte und
hoher Personalaufwand werden kritisiert
außerdem gibt es eine hohe Anzahl von
Gesetzen und Verordnungen und weil
ebenenso viel Geld in die Bürokratie
fließt verzichten viele Unternehmen auch
auf Investitionen im Schnitt wenden die
Betriebe mehr als 3% ihres Jahres
Umsatzes für diese bürokratischen
Pflichten auf und was fordert die
Branche welche Vorschriften sollten weg
also ganz konkret sollen Berichts und
Dokumentationspflichten reduziert werden
ebenso sollen Antrags und
Genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigt
werden fordert der gesamtmetallverband
diese Umfrage zeigt auch den Grad der
Entfremdung zwischen Wirtschaft und
Politik unter anderem deshalb fordert
der Verband den Bürokratieabbau zur
Chefsache in der Politik zu erklären und
mächtigberg auf ging es heute am
deutschen Aktienmarkt der Dax reichte
zwischenzeitlich ein neues Allzeithoch
und beendet den Handel mit
16533 Punkten die Börse beflügeln
sinkete Inflationszahlen in der Eurozone
und die Hoffnung dass die Zinsen zeitnah
sogar wieder sinken könnten vielen Dank
für alle Informationen sin
meinitz zum Fußball das DFB Pokal
Achtelfinale läuft zwei Partien sind
schon beendet demnach ist der erste FC
Kaisers laautern weiter nach dem 2:0
Sieg gegen Zweitliga Rivale Nürnberg
auch Fortuna Düsseldorf steht erstmals
seit vier Jahren wieder im Viertelfinale
nach dem 2:1 Auswärtssieg in Magdeburg
die Begegnung VfB Stuttgart Borussia
Dortmund morgen Abend live im
ZDF die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen
hatte am Abend ein wichtiges Spiel in
der nations League es ging um die
Teilnahme an den Olympischen
Sommerspielen 24 in Paris mit einem Sieg
in diesem Gruppenspiel hätte sich das
dfbteam sicher für die Finalrunde
qualifiziert es war aber eine
Zitterpartie die mit einem 0:0 endete
weil parallel Island Dänemark besiegte
bleibt Deutschland Gruppensieger und
sichert sich damit die Chance auf
Olympia ein Spaziergang auf dem Mond ein
Moonwalk ein Menschheitstraum der
Millionen fasziniert darunter
Berühmtheiten wie Hollywood Star Tom
Hanks seit seiner Kindheit ist er
versessen auf alles was mit Raumfahrt
Weltall und Mondlandungen zu tun hat er
träumte davon selbst asronaut zu werden
und das wurde dann zwar nur auf der
Leinwand aber das Thema ließ ihn nie los
zumal ja eine neue Mondmission geplant
ist mit Blick darauf hat Hanks jetzt
eine Multimedia Show in London
organisiert unter dem Titel The
moonwalkers eine an die Raumfahrt ihre
frühen und künftigen Helden und was es
dort zu sehen gibt und was Tom hangs
dazu sagt berichtet Hilke
Petersen ein Star mit einer Leidenschaft
Tom Hanks unterwegs im Weltraum es ist
eine Reise in Bildern vom
Menschheitstraum wieder auf dem Mond zu
landen vielleicht schon
bald der Lightroom in London hier sind
die Bilder riesengroß die moonwalkers
Show eindringlich ein neuer Trend nicht
nur Zuschauer sein sondern
mittendrin der Weltraum begeisterte Tom
Hanks erzählt die Geschichte wie Apollo
vor über 50 Jahren zuletzt Menschen zum
Mond brachte und die neue Artemis
Mission erforschen soll ob bald ein
Außenposten für die Menschheit möglich
wird niemand wird dadurch reich werden
es wird kein Territorium erobert im
Namen irgendeiner Nation oder eines
Unternehmens oder ar irgendeiner
theologischen
Bewegung es geht darum dass Menschen die
nächste Phase ihrer Existenz als
weltraumfahrende Kreaturen
einleuten die Crew der nächsten
nasamondmission Artemis 2 zum ersten Mal
sind ein Afroamerikaner und eine Frau
dabei ab
2025 dass der berühmte Schauspieler ihre
Mission bekannt macht begeistert sie
wie gesegnet sind wir dass Tom Hanks ein
solches Interesse an dieser Sache hat
und sich wirklich dafür einsetzt diese
Geschichten zu erzählen und alles ist
hier echt es gibt keine Computergrafiken
alles Bilder von Menschen gemacht
wirklich
stark h kennt sich aus mit
Schwerelosigkeit Mitte der 90er ist der
Captain der Apollo 13 Mission im
Filmers Tom h die NASA smallt mit der
Besatzung der
ISS und wie unter Kollegen im
Fachgespräch mit der
artemisk zum Mond zu fliegen das ist
eine Sache aber zum Mond zu fliegen und
weit entfernt von der Erde zu leben dass
das möglich und normal wird ist etwas
anderes wenn sie ihn ließen Tom HS wäre
sofort
dabei ich würde meine eigene Unterwäsche
und ein Dosenöffner mit bring ich mache
alles solange es nichts mit Mathematik
zu tun
hat die Musik für das Space Spektakel in
den legendären Abby Road Studios
produziert wo auch die Beatles
spielten der Sound macht die Reise zum
Mond noch intensiver für jeden der mit
will bis zum 21
[Musik]
April ja das Tom h ist nicht so mit
Mathematik hat schließt sich heute ein
Kreis das war's von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht's weiter mit der
Reportagereihe 37° und um Mitternacht
meldet sich also wieder Christopher
weermann mit unserem heute journal
Update auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend das kleine
Schneeregen und glatteisregentief zieht
morgen weiter nach Nordosten und dann
schubst dieses Tiefdruck Ballett hier
über Westeuropa ein kleines Zwischenhoch
zu uns rein das uns am Donnerstag beehrt
heute Nacht allerdings müssen sie sich
noch mal auf Glatteis einstellen und
zwar in diesem Streifen von Oldenburg
über Bremen und Hamburg bis nach Berlin
nördlich davon fällt Schnee sonst gibt's
noch einige schneeregens Schauer der
Schnee beschränkt sich auf die
Mittelgebirge und im Schwarzwald können
bis morgen Abend durchaus noch mal 15 cm
Neuschnee fallen und dem kräftigen
Südwestwind wird dieser Neuschnee dann
auch verweht die Temperaturen heute
Nacht sinken auf 4° am oberrein und bis
- 3° ganz im Osten und morgen liegen
dann die Höchsttemperaturen hier im
Nordosten um 0° 6° werden es am Rin und
morgen früh kann es im Nordosten noch
mal gefährlich glatt sein dann aber
lassen die Schnee und Regenfälle doch
mehr und mehr nach und am Nachmittag
wird es dann westlich des reins schon
ganz freundlich und das ist dann das
kleine Zwischenhoch das einmal über uns
hinwegzieht dann aber kommt schon ein
stürmisches nächstes tieferan und am
Freitag wird damit dann die nächste
Runde Glatteisregen bei uns eingelutet
nach einem freundlichen Donnerstag also
nach Nebel mit Sonnenschein gibt's dann
wieder Glatteisregen in der Westhälfte
Deutschlands am Freitag im Osten ist es
noch freundlicher und zum zweiten
Adventswochenende setzt dann Tauwetter
ein guten
Abend